[Applaudissements]
pas du tout on fait n'importe quoi ça va
s'arranger alors je vous le dis sans
lacets imed qui veulent qu'on soit tous
ces gars de là tout va mal je vous le
dis comme je crois qu'il ya des enfants
au régime nazi et à bouder qui est un
petit garçon sa mère et lui dit va
acheter de la confiture
parce qu'en fait cette pénurie de
confiture dans le quartier elle lui dit
va chez cet épicier je suis sûr qu'il
aura il y va monsieur l'épicier maman
aveux de la confiture dit ça tombe bien
j'ai la confiture qui vient des états
unis et il entend sonner comme un fou de
joie il prend la confiture il y va et
sur le chemin j'ai dit confitures des
états unis ben écoute et à nu alors ils
ouvrent regarde ma bouche personnes
leurs gardes
gibbs il roulait quand il parle des
faits salle rossini sa mère maman
gymnase et ses confitures
c'est ça ça mardi mais ses proches
brutalement ses confitures elle prend
jamais c'est pas possible avant le raid
en salle de bain il s'en dit mais c'est
pas un gars lequel il prend la confiture
ne sais quelle famille malade
foot vallée loire et vhc dit c'est pas
sur les pistes
c'est long c'est d'avoir produit une
confiture périmés le colisée l'épicier
dit si vous n'êtes pas contents allez
vous plaindre au cou mais ça là il va
lui c'est pas moi le commissariat puis 3
1 mais excusez moi le commissariat s'il
vous plaît lautier fait
on a une nouvelle personne autour de la
table alors ça n'est pas à ce qu'ils
aient invité aujourd'hui il y a fanny
negish à fanny guichard
il y avait sûrement arriver avec
benjamin castadi vendredi soir une bonne
et j'ai envie de faire un truc tout de
suite et pas prévu j'ai envie de faire
gagner un truc au public à tous
il va partir de gaz c'est l'invité
je vous ai dit
[Applaudissements]
allez
ça finlandais qui invite un arabe et un
anglais un français chez lui pour pour
manger pour faire un petit barbecue qui
mangent ils font un barbecue et où tout
se passe bien et où ils sont reclus et
où il décide d'aller à la piscine qui
vont à la piscine et tout est là tu as
l'anglais qui sautent dans la piscine et
il voit qu'il ya un crocodile dans la
piscine de l'anglais for mac adam raga
dans my god il veut pour sortir de la
piscine et tout n'arrive pas le
crocodile de le beauf natale français
qui sont dans la piscine ils voient
crocodile est dû à mon dieu oh mon dieu
un crocodile au monde y va pour sortir
la piscine n'y arrive pas il le beauf la
tal arabe qui sautent dans la piscine
comme ça et là il voit le crocodile et
regarde le finlandais idf ça fait que la
piscine lacoste 1 ce matin bfm tv a
diffusé un sujet qui a fait énormément
réagir aujourd'hui un sujet qui évoque
l'hypothèse d'un candidat surprise pour
l'élection présidentielle de 2000 22 ils
ont pensé à moi donc c'est un ministre
proche des manuels vacon macro qui
aurait confié son inquiétude de me voir
candidat jeu plus et plus envie de plus
faire dans l'associatif tout ça bah oui
il va présenter à une élection
présidentielle voilà on est en train de
travailler sur mon avis poteau qui va
être une association qui va aider
énormément d'eau je pense que la
priorité elle est plus là en fait vous
aimez bien rassembler un jour
ce public est là tous les jours devant
leur poste et enfin ce serait
extraordinaire je suis fier que vous
aimez vous détestez le communautarisme
zemit rassembler les gens faire en sorte
que les gens se parlent
non ce serait en fait plein de plans de
plein de gens différents ce qui compose
la france ils iraient tous la france est
à nous la france est à nous la force est
à nous elle est dit et ça finit sur la
france est à new marais je crois que ça
provoque rognant famille paré vous avez
fait de la danse pendant très longtemps
ouais c'est vrai par exemple dans ce
prêt j'ai alors dans tmp qui est une
émission média d'autres cultures
[Applaudissements]
là
la page
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
oui je venais de bons retours et
on voudrait bien en appelant à donner
une chance à notre amour redonner un
élan à notre histoire
tu ne regardes pas tout tu es la seule à
avoir le numéro
fatou ah non alors à tous
alors depuis ses débuts dans tpm paix
qu'il y a bien changé et c'est vrai que
l à un autre petit amoureux dans
l'émission
[Applaudissements]
elle
g
[Musique]
m
on va éviter de marcher les mains crabes
mais on va marcher ensemble à
donc tu laissais de ne plus marcher seul
comme jean jacques goldman non non je ne
m'attendais pas j'aurai marché avec
ville par de comble de bonheur
[Musique]
on va rendre de l'autre beaucoup des
béquilles plus forte star et à ceux qui
ont envie de dire que c'est l'homme de
ma vie
on va inventer on va avancer
tranquillement battu tranquillement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]